as you may have heard september 19th has
been since time out of mind or at least
2002 observed as international talk like
a pirate day
the idea came first from two oregonians
john bauer and mark summers although
oregon is not well known as a land of
pirates
it gained publicity when it was
championed by the comedian dave berry in
a column on september 8th of that year
in which he opined i truly think this
idea could bring us as a nation closer
together
talk like a pirate day has since become
an opportunity for frolic some good fun
for pirate lovers of all creeds and ages
fun for all except for tiresome patents
like me who every year grit our teeth
and roll our eyes because pirates did
not you know really say are
as far as nautical and popular
historians can tell the notion that all
pirates stump around growling r didn't
exist until the movies and books in the
early 20th century and it was really
popularized in 1950 by the actor robert
newton
in disney's blockbuster film treasure
island newton used his native dorset
accent when he played long john silver
and it included a rolled r
now certainly there were some west
country sailors who turned pirate and
they may well have retained their
dialect roldar but they would hardly
have represented the majority of pirate
speakers
in fact pirate crews in piracy's golden
age were polyglot made up of men from
not just all over britain but all over
europe and indeed the world
pirate crews were even more likely to be
multi-ethnic than naval and merchant
crews
believe it or not johnny depp's
caribbean inflected slang from pirates
of the caribbean might well be closer to
authentic pirate speech if you subtract
the keith richards mumble from his
performance
to be fair
bauer and summers know this and they
have tried to educate the pirate loving
public as they say on their website the
patron saint of talk like a pirate day
is the late robert newton but we like
johnny depp too
but i've been teaching courses on pirate
stuff to highly intelligent culturally
aware college students for more than a
decade not to mention blathering on
about pirates to my phd holding
colleagues for longer than that
and i have to say the origin of the
pirate r is still not what i'd call
common knowledge
the patents innate impulse to be a
killjoy aside my point here is that we
grow up with pirate stories long before
we have any chance at exposure to pirate
scholarship and consequently a great
deal of what we think we know or feel is
true about piracy doesn't come to us
from historical texts except in the most
roundabout way possible
most of it really comes from popular
culture from films and fictions the root
of horror isn't so much a reverence for
the ancient practice of piracy per se
as it's an inspiration of the popular
boys adventure book written by the
scottish author robert louis stevenson
in 1881
the one that was the basis for disney's
treasure island film
in this lesson we're going to look at
some of the most common things we hear
about pirates and piracy and also take a
look at what the historical record
actually has to say about them
as i've said much of our sense of the
pirates appeal originates in literary
rather than historical texts although
we'll also see that if you go back far
enough the distinction between the two
becomes pretty blurry
we'll start with some vexillology
one of the first things that will jump
to mind if i say pirate to most of the
people in my classrooms is a familiar
black flag maybe whipping in the wind
and emblazoned with some sort of skull
and crossbones image in white
we call this the jolly roger and you'll
be relieved to learn that this unlike
the pyratical world r was a real thing
but it's also true that pirates did
complicated things with their flags and
a well-stocked pirate ship would ideally
have far more than just a single black
flag with a death's head on it
possibly the first pirate to try out the
effect of what is now their traditional
jolly roger was immanuel wynne who in
1700 unfurled a sable ensign with
crossbones a death's head and an
hourglass
black flags either plain or decorated
with bones can be found going back at
least to the medieval period and it's
also possible that the caribbean use of
such flags was inspired by the designs
on the flags of barbary corsairs in the
mediterranean
whatever the origin these black flags
caught on quickly in the 18th century
caribbean and many pirate ships
personalize them with symbols such as
skeletons skulls daggers hearts initials
or hourglasses
here's an example from an eyewitness
account of a pirate attack in 1716 by
the pirate captain martell
an unidentified swift sailing ship with
only three men visible on deck appeared
and came dangerously close to the
greyhound galley which was a ship full
of african captives imprisoned by the
slave trade
the mysterious ship answered no hails
but closed the distance fired a shot and
at the same time let fly her jack ensign
and pendant that's three separate flags
in which was the figure of a man with a
sword in his hand and an hourglass
before him with a death's head and bones
in the jack and pendant were only the
head and crossbones
the triple appearance of the jolly roger
was not to be argued with after only one
more shot the officers of the greyhound
surrendered
so what this tells us is that the skull
and crossbones was real and was
effective unfurling it was an act that
claimed the identity of piracy and its
main use was to frighten victims into
giving up without much resistance
this worked so well in part because real
pirates used both red and black flags
and the one you really didn't want to
see was the red one which might have a
skull and crossbones on it or might not
a black pirate flag meant quarter would
be given if the enemy surrendered
meaning they spare your life after
rifling through your cargo indeed while
the pirates in the example we just saw
were not very nice to the captain of the
greyhound they ultimately let both him
and his ship go
red though was the traditional nautical
symbol for no quarter given it was
favored by mcgrabby corsairs and used in
the caribbean as well
as a letter to the british journal about
a 1724 pirate attack explained they
hoisted jolly roger for so they call
their black ensign when they fight under
jolly roger they give quarter which they
do not when they fight under the red or
bloody flag
the purpose of the jolly roger then was
actually to remind pirate victims that
things could be worse if they didn't
cooperate
in any case such tricks were for special
occasions and pirates most frequently
sailed under national colors both
through and falls disguising themselves
as law-abiding european ships in order
to try to get close to their
unsuspecting prey or passed by any
hunters unnoticed indeed the practice of
using false flags at sea was commonly
accepted for lawful vessels as well as
pirates privateers of course were
supposed to use national colors like the
union jack
incidentally no one seems to know where
the term jolly roger comes from
there's an idea that it may be a
mispronunciation of jolie rouge the
french for pretty red
or perhaps it conflates jolie rouge and
old roger which was a colloquial english
name for the devil that dated back at
least to about seventeen hundred
the problem is that the french called
the iconic red flag a song cortier gives
no quarter not jolie rouge
also in play may be the fact that roger
has a double meaning in english it was
both a man's name and a euphemism for
the male sex organ
so the bad news is that much about the
jolly roger remains hazy
we have very few surviving examples of
pirate flags what we do have indicates
that there was quite a bit of variation
in the practice of pirate symbolism
while we have enough eyewitness accounts
of the jolly roger to have some idea of
what such a flag could look like the
origin of the standard remains murky
we don't quite know why it became
popular among pirates or why they called
it that
but the good news is that there's plenty
of basis to believe in this particular
pirate legend
alas we cannot say the same for probably
the second most beloved pirate legend
the trove of buried treasure
as we'll explore in greater detail in a
future discussion this just wasn't very
likely to happen
most of your standard golden age pirates
did the maritime equivalent of robbing a
couple of 7-elevens sold what they could
and then drifted away into a quiet
mostly law abiding retirement the
average length of a pirate career was no
more than one to three years
a few pirates did strike real wealth
some of the men who followed thomas ii
henry every and william kidd walked away
with hundreds of pounds even by
conservative estimates
but this was not the common case
and such lucky pirates had no
predilection for burying their hordes
like maritime dragons
what money they acquired they tended to
spend quickly the medieval and viking
hordes that we still find from time to
time are usually theorized to be either
burial treasures or treasure buried to
protect it from pirates rather than done
by pirates
captain kidd whom you'll recall from the
previous lesson was not much of a pirate
was rumored to have buried a cache of
spoils on gardner's island in new york
but this seems unlikely it's true that
fearing arrest kid had tried to disperse
and hide much of his booty but he did so
in the more conventional way of buying
and selling and leaving it with various
people most of whom were found and
persuaded to cough up the ill-gotten
gains by his persecutor the earl of
belmont
one version of the anonymous 18th
century ballad of captain kid promises i
90 bars of gold and dollars manifold
with riches uncontrolled come all ye
young and old you're welcome to my gold
for buy it i've lost my soul and must
die
but no one got the 90 bars in some
versions it was 200 either way just a
legend
in the end the only wealth that golden
rumor ever produced was literary
washington irving the author of rip van
winkle and the legend of sleepy hollow
wrote a set of immensely popular pirate
stories in 1824 called the money diggers
that featured dutch american farmers
tearing up their cabbage fields in
search of kids non-existent booty
and in the mid-19th century kidd became
a feature of melodrama like the highly
popular captain kid or the wizard of the
sea a romance 1839
which led credulous audiences to believe
his sunken treasure ship lays somewhere
in the hudson river
robert louis stevenson also contributed
to the myth of the buried treasure horde
his best-selling 1882 boys adventure
story treasure island and to a lesser
extent the 1889 master of ballentre
both revolve around buried treasure
plots
both helped to cement the idea of pirate
gold in the imagination of children and
their parents
the confluence of fiction and history in
stevenson is interesting
ballentre is set between 1745 and 1764
and it features a pirate who
deliberately imitates the historical
pirate blackbeard about who more shortly
stevenson doesn't date the events of
treasure island precisely but based on
the events it references it seems to
take place in the late 1750s
so that ultimate pirate novel was
composed in the late 19th century but it
stars pirates from the earlier golden
age of piracy which took place in the
caribbean and atlantic ocean from about
1650 to the end of the 1720s
stevenson also name checks several real
pirates like captain blackbeard and
captain england but he mixes in a lot of
anachronisms from the sailors he'd grown
up seeing
most of his pirates for example sport
tattoos and earrings
tattoos weren't popular among sailors
until the end of the 18th century when
south seas explorations became more
common
earrings had been fashionable for men in
the early 17th century king charles the
first reportedly wore his favorite pearl
drop earring to his own beheaded
and the sea dog walter raleigh wore
pearls in both of his ears
but with the interregnum earrings fell
out of fashion even for sailors until
the end of the 18th century as well
treasure island is a good example of how
cultures take the pirate stories of
previous eras and adjust them to fit
their own desires stevenson himself
admitted to borrowing or we might say
pirating from washington irving's money
digger stories one good pirate yarn
begets another
the interesting thing is that these
newly modified pirate fictions can then
become a part of collective folklore for
future generations
but all this is not to downplay the fact
that the historical kernels behind the
legends are often dramatic and
terrifying without the subsequent
mythologizing
and to be fair in the 17th and 18th
centuries there was no hard and fast
line between history and fiction
reportage and storytelling
the pirate edward thatch or teach alias
blackbeard stands out both as a figure
who generated extraordinary fear in his
day for his notorious deeds and as an
instance of the way pirate fact and
pirate fiction could merge to become
something entirely new
remarkable for his ferocity and defiance
the historical blackbeard does not
appear to have been an especially
wealthy pirate but he managed to
accumulate fame even without wealth his
name recognition is probably the highest
among all golden age caribbean pirates
i may have disappointed you with the
news that pirates don't talk like
pirates and that captain kidd was
neither a good pirate nor the keeper of
buried treasure so perhaps it will be of
some comfort to hear that blackbeard was
perfectly real reportedly terrifying and
he actually
did have a really memorable beard
blackbeard was a successful pirate in
terms of the damage he brought and his
legend grew partly because he destroyed
ships where many other pirates would
have just let them go after a little
plundering throwing overboard goods that
his crew had no uses for rather than
letting the unfortunate merchants retain
them
for example when boston hanged six
pirates in 1717 blackbeard vowed to burn
all new england ships he came across as
a punishment for the coastal colonies
effrontery and he is known to have
burned the ship protestant caesar and
all its cargo to the waterline
interestingly he was not particularly
murderous for a pirate even with all the
unparalleled property destruction
he seemed to get along a bit better with
the southern colonies at least for a
time though he certainly annoyed the
coastal planters
governor eden of north carolina was a
great deal less active in suppressing
piracy than the governors of virginia
and south carolina which may be related
to the inconvenient fact that some of
blackbeard's loot was found in the barn
of the governor's secretary after
blackbeard was defeated
eden hotly contested the well-published
implication that he was being bribed by
a pirate by the way but his reputation
never really recovered
whether or not he benefited from
government connivance blackbeard was
believed to be violent and was
reportedly smart about using his
reputation for violence to strike fear
into both his enemies and his own men
here's a typical anecdote of his
character from a general history of the
pirates an important work that we'll
discuss more in future lessons
one night drinking in his cabin with
hands the pilot and another man
blackbeard without any provocation
privately draws out a small pair of
pistols and [ __ ] them under the table
which being perceived by the man he
withdrew and went up on the deck leaving
hands the pilot and the captain together
when the pistols were ready he blew out
the candle and crossing his hands
discharged them at his company hands the
master was shot through the knee and
laned for life
the other pistol did no execution
being asked the meaning of this he only
answered by damning them that if he did
not now and then kill one of them they
would forget who he was
as is true of much in the general
history
it's hard to know exactly how far to
trust this story it speaks of thatch's
reputation but is not necessarily
consistent with the facts
israel hands had apparently been a
trusted boson to blackbeard often
commanding ships that sailed in consort
with thatch
hands was not among the pirates captured
when blackbeard was ultimately defeated
but was instead arrested in bath north
carolina where he may have been
recovering from a knee wound or maybe
wasn't
he received a pardon for dustifying
against the other pirates and was one of
only two in the crew to escape being
hanged
hansa's name would reappear centuries
later in stevenson's treasure island
where he was a major antagonist to the
main character jim hawkins although in
treasure island hans was said to have
sailed with captain flint and he is shot
to death by jim not in the knee by a
drunken pirate
but back to blackbeard's black beard
which according to lieutenant maynard
was so long and glorious that he tied it
up in black ribbons
you should know that in the 1720s
western european men wore their faces
clean-shaven
even infamous and feared pirates like
captain bartholomew roberts and other
pirates are consistently depicted this
way in illustrations sometimes they're
even wearing wigs too some men shave
their heads as well as their faces to
the english wearing a beard at all
marked a man as alien and maybe a little
bit barbaric
there may have been some connection
between the horror attached to
blackbeard's visage and the
mediterranean corsairs who were far more
likely than european pirates to wear
beards
the name of the famous corsairing
barbarossa brothers whom we'll return to
another day means red beard in italian
although portraits show them as being
dark-haired
thatch's facial hair in connecting him
to barbary corsairs could have seemed
like a rejection of european identity
and norms
and of christianity as a part of that
thatch's kind of brutal rebellion
against european norms would have been
in character for a man who named one of
his flagships the queen anne's revenge
that name suggested a political
allegiance to the jacobite movement
which at its extreme end advocated the
overthrow of england's then-reigning
royal family the hanoverians and the
restoration of the stewart dynasty
blackbeard's jacobitism seems to have
been a tone or a mood rather than a
matter of actual allegiance though there
was no evidence that he had any active
connection to trying to restore the
stewards
the point it seems was to enhance his
fearsome reputation and he apparently
went to some pains to do so
the most vivid description of his
appearance as usual comes from the
general history of the pirates
captain teach we are told
assumed the cognamen of blackbeard from
that large quantity of hair which like a
frightful meteor covered his whole face
and frightened america more than any
comet that has appeared there a long
time
this beard was black which he suffered
to grow of an extravagant length as to
bread that came up to his eyes he was
accustomed to twist it with ribbons in
small tales and turn them about his ears
in time of action he stuck lighted
matches under his hat which appearing on
each side of his face his eyes naturally
looking fierce and wild made him
altogether such a figure that
imagination cannot form an idea of a
fury from hell to look more frightful
this image understandably captured the
imagination of the public and circulated
in wood cuts and engravings as well as
words
and as it circulated it was embellished
for example the notion arose that
blackbeard let his own beard on fire
before battle and he's often depicted
that way in later illustrations most
recently take a look at the posters for
pirates of the caribbean on stranger
tides that feature actor ian mcshane's
blackbeard with glowing beard tendrils
but that's because contemporary
illustrations which were often pretty
rough made it easy to confuse his beard
which he tucked over his ears with the
sparklers hanging down from his hat
edward thatcher's death was as extreme
as his life and predictably generated
accounts with varying degrees of
adherence to reality
in fact the american author and
statesman benjamin franklin claimed that
one of his first publications done at
the tender age of 13 was a popular
ballot about blackbeard's death entitled
the downfall of piracy
it was really pretty bad
will you hear of a bloody battle lately
fought upon the seas it will make your
ears to rattle and your admiration seize
in contrast to bows that depicted
pirates as bold rebels like those
centered on the englishman john ward or
henry every franklin's aim was to
glorify not the pirate but lieutenant
maynard and the sailors of the royal
navy who defeated blackbeard and the
crew of his ship the adventure in 1718
near ocracoke island north carolina
this would have surely pleased the
governor of virginia who thought
ocracoke was being turned into a
pirate's stronghold
neighboring colonial governors often had
divergent views of piracy
but whatever its actual details the
battle does indeed appear to have been
bloody and dramatic as maynard's men
strained aboard thatch's ship at least
according to maynard's self-serving
account later published in the weekly
journal of british gazetteer
the pirate raised a glass and drank
damnation to me and my men whom he
styled cowardly puppies saying he would
neither give nor take quarter
the boston newsletter supplies the
detail that after blackbeard had wounded
maynard's sword hand and apparently
survived a pistol shot he was brought
down by a powerful scottish highlander
who gave teach a cut on the neck teach
saying well done lad the highlander
replied if it be not well done i'll do
it better with that he gave him a second
stroke which cut off his head laying it
flat on his shoulder
this detail has the air of fiction about
it and the general history in contrast
suggests that blackbeard simply
succumbed suddenly to his wounds
but it's certain blackbeard fell in
battle
maynard recorded that thatch's corpse
showed at least five bullet holes and
some 20 sword cuts all over his body and
though we're not sure who beheaded him
we do know that the lieutenant hung his
disembodied head from the ship's prow
both the general history and the
governor of virginia recorded that
blackbeard had left a man below with
orders to blow up his ship in the event
of defeat and that the plot was narrowly
averted by the intervention of a
prisoner samuel o'dell who was arrested
with the pirates but later acquitted at
trial
of course the general history also
relates accounts from surviving members
of blackbeard's crew that the devil
himself was among them on that fateful
night so you can see the challenge that
it presents to historians
as i mentioned earlier
blackbeard's piracy doesn't appear to
have made him rich
maynard's victorious men eagerly
searched the adventure for booty but
found only some gold dust and a few
small bits of stolen silver here and
there along with stolen cocoa and some
sugar
lest we be overly persuaded by
franklin's heroic vision of maynard it's
worth noting that he enslaved and sold
the african men he found among
blackbeard's surviving crew to increase
his profit threshold
the wreck of what may very well be
blackbeard's other famous ship the queen
anne's revenge was located and
excavation began in 1996
objects found aboard are as varied as
belt buckles to wine bottles to an enema
syringe but there's not much sign of
treasure
nevertheless blackbeard's legend rapidly
morphed to incorporate any number of
outlandish claims
in 1724 for example charles johnson
depicted him as a despoiler of virgins
and a polygamist although there are no
other contemporary claims about his
sexual proclivities being anything
remarkable
and as his name recognition grew it
became curiously detached from the man
himself
and instead turned into something of a
free-floating signifier for anything
pirate-like at all
you can get a sense of this in one of
the most popular melodramas of the
entire 19th century one that we'll
return to later on in the series john
cartwright crosses tragic comedy
blackbeard or the captive princess
it's the musical and special effects
spectacular that features blackbeard
hoarding a massive treasure in
madagascar capturing and falling in love
with the princess of the mughal empire
and being haunted by the ghost of the
jealous first wife he'd murdered
this very different depiction of
blackbeard is still bold and commanding
and interestingly he's still brought
down by a heroic lieutenant maynard in
the fiery last act but there ends the
resemblance
the effect of this hugely popular
reimagining of blackbeard away from the
carolina coastline and into the bosom of
a fainting female captive gave great
power to the long tradition of the
lustful stage swashbuckler
yet in large part the lovelorn pirate
was an invention of 19th century popular
culture given legitimacy by its
attachment to works by sir walter scott
and the brooding george gordon lord
byron
what can we take from this admittedly
confusing mix of pirate reality and
imagination
i'd emphasize that the uncertainties and
ambiguities that surround real pirates
of the golden age were there from the
very start
and even the most outlandish stories we
tell ourselves and our kids today often
have at least a small archival basis
walking the plank though was not
something pirates routinely made people
do
stay tuned to find out why